shh
hear that
silence
we often equate communication with
talking but not talking that is
listening
is as important if not more important
i'm matt abrahams and i teach strategic
communication at stanford graduate
school of business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
today i am so excited to be joined by my
strategic communication teaching partner
and long time friend kristen hansen
beyond teaching our class kristin
recently co-taught leadership for
society big arguments courageous
leadership
beyond her lecturing at the gsb kristin
is the executive director of the civic
health project and a board member of the
listen first project
hey there partner welcome to the podcast
ready to have some fun
well matt i always have fun talking and
teaching with you in fact there's
nothing i'd rather be doing every monday
before eight o'clock in the morning
it is quite early there are lots of
things i would rather do before
but i i truly enjoy teaching with you
let's go ahead and get started
we have known each other for a long
long time we taught our first public
speaking class together in stanford's
engineering school while undergraduates
three decades ago well as they say matt
time flies when you're having fun and
things get better with age at least i
hope
back then we had a lot of fun helping
our students communicate better what are
one or two best practices you find
yourself still highlighting after all of
these years
our challenge
back at that time was helping students
in technical degree programs to convey
complex ideas in more accessible ways
and to this day that is something i
still really enjoy and i know you do too
helping students craft engaging story
lines from dense
complex or highly technical material and
you know i also remembered we helped
students reduce filler words like uh um
and like from their verbal
communications we would actually bang a
book on the desk each time they did it
well we don't bank books anymore do we
but we still help students to be more
confident and fluid in their verbal
delivery i remember banging books
ringing bells clapping hands and and
today of course there's an app for that
you know one thing many folks don't know
about you is that you were a true
pioneer in virtual communication our
students really enjoy and get a kick out
of
showing the video we have of you selling
the first video conference technologies
from the last century okay matt now
you're really making me feel old but
you're right i actually worked for the
early 1990s version of zoom
thinking back to then and and bringing
it forward to now what are a couple of
the best practices you can share about
hybrid and virtual communication
effective virtual communication both
then and now is so much about getting
the setup right
is my network connection strong and
reliable how's my lighting should i use
headphones with a mic pro tip yes you
should do i have permission from the
other side to display my slides getting
any of these things wrong risks losing
your audience before you've even gotten
underway and once the show begins it's
about finding ways to leap out of your
screen how do i let my audience know
that not only do they see me i see them
effective virtual communication is about
closing the distance and coming across
bigger than that little screen that
holds you
so many important points there about
presence about engagement about
permission but the one thing i heard you
say that i really want to dig deep into
that helped me so much when we went
virtual was the notion of it's a show
you helped me understand that you have
to plan and coordinate your virtual
communication you have to think about
the timing who speaks when how quickly
do you move from one thing to the other
just like you're an executive producer
of a television show and once i started
doing that it freed me up to be more of
myself
in my virtual communication so thank you
for that personally and thank you for
the advice you shared with all of us
i'd like now to shift gears from talking
and presenting which is what we
primarily help our students with here at
the business school to listening which
is a big focus of your work outside of
the business school can you describe
that work and how it relates to the
principle of listening first well after
getting my mba here at stanford and
enjoying a long career in the tech
sector i started worrying a few years
ago and i know i'm not alone about what
seemed like an alarming deterioration in
our civil discourse here in the u.s
infecting our politics our media even
just everyday interactions among
families friends neighbors
and for me that sense of alarm prompted
me to pivot out of tech and into an
emerging sector in our country full of
organizations that are focused on
helping americans to bridge our social
cultural and political divides
so now i run a philanthropy it's called
civic health project and we help
organizations that are doing bridge
building work across the u.s and i also
serve on the board of listen first
project hashtag listen first the
umbrella organization that represents
hundreds
literally hundreds of grassroots bridge
building organizations across the
country
collectively this whole field is focused
on a pretty monumental task we're trying
to shift norms in our country toward
listening and away from cancelling
toward intellectual humility and away
from absolutism and virtue signaling
toward curiosity and away from animosity
i so respect the efforts that you and
your colleagues are doing to really help
make a difference in in our civil
discourse and i can see so clearly how
you can apply the skills that we teach
our students i'm curious if we can bring
this back to a very tactical
set of advice and guidance what are some
best practices you've learned that
leaders managers and employees
can use to help listen better well
there's no silver bullet here but it's
important to understand that better
listening starts with intent
listening actively and deeply happens
when i genuinely believe that the person
who's speaking has intrinsic worth and
brings a perspective that i lack and i
need
in work settings just like in our
personal lives our relationships thrive
when we cultivate our own
open-mindedness
intellectual humility
genuine curiosity
i love how the book conscious leadership
by john mackey and steve mcintosh
explores this idea of cultivating an
integral
view urging business leaders to
appreciate and synthesize
employees diverse backgrounds and
beliefs and perspectives when aiming to
resolve conflict or make transformative
change
active listening is at the core of
developing this more integral world view
and when we listen it isn't a passive
exercise
active inquiry is part of listening to
the trick is asking genuine questions
that open up new pathways for
understanding
now this can really feel hard when the
viewpoints or the values that are being
expressed by somebody else challenge our
own
including in our workplaces but that is
also when the greatest opportunity for
learning presents itself even if we
understand this intuitively it is it is
hard to do practicing listening just
like practicing speaking is so critical
one of the key elements that you talked
about kristin was this notion of how you
approach it it's your mindset
many of us listen just enough to try to
understand what the person's saying
rather than really deeply try to figure
out the nuance the meaning
i like to
instruct people to listen by trying to
figure out what's the bottom line of
what the person's saying now i have to
say
i might be better at teaching this than
actually doing it you know in the
conversations we have sometimes i don't
listen well and my wife reminds me all
the time that i don't listen as well as
i can
but we need to listen with intent and
then i really like what you said about
inquiry following so it's not just about
listening it's about synthesizing and
then following up through listening and
paraphrasing
last fall you co-taught with brian lowry
a former guest here
a class called leadership for society
big arguments courageous leadership what
was the main thrust of that course and
what takeaways can you share with us
co-teaching that course big arguments
courageous leadership with dean lowry
was a chance to
equip students here at the business
school with some of the theories out of
social psychology as well as the tools
and practices
to help listen better contemplate
different perspectives
and navigate conflicts where they emerge
from the boardroom to the school board
to thanksgiving weekend with family
one of the main concepts that we urged
our students to contemplate and focus on
is developing and applying that integral
worldview that considers and synthesizes
different perspectives among diverse
workforces and citizenries and just to
broaden that a bit beyond workplaces
and leadership roles that many of our
students will go on to inhabit in the
workplace you know just looking at our
society as americans today by now we can
all see that the shouting the posturing
the grandstanding it isn't really
getting us anywhere one of my favorite
quotes from a colleague mark gerzon is
the world today has an advocacy surplus
and an inquiry deficit
these massive societal challenges that
we're facing they're not going to get
solved if we just sort and retreat into
tribal factions we label americans
outside our own tribes as enemies we
lose any sense of trust or goodwill
towards one another
social science research and this is a
lot of what we delved into in the course
it makes it clear that when we engage
in deep genuine
listening
perspective taking and perspective
sharing so that is hearing other
people's lived experiences and honestly
sharing our own
that's how we get down to the root
that's how we begin to cultivate deep
reservoirs of trust good will
and empathy toward one another and that
is a recipe for success in business and
in our civic life so much there that is
so important you know the the foundation
of this podcast is really based on some
of those principles it's really better
understanding yourself being able to
listen and then respond and communicate
in a way that is connected respectful
and hopefully positively directed
towards solving problems
achieving goals pitching well
given the wide variety of topics you
teach do you have any last ideas you'd
like to share here's my chance to plug
the idea that business can actually be
uniquely impactful in helping to shift
people in our society and other
societies away from deep division and
toward greater social cohesion through
skills that include listening inquiry
perspective sharing and so on and there
and there are three reasons for this
first of all
we know that business leaders are more
highly trusted than nearly all other
institutional leaders in our society so
there's receptivity to the idea that
business leadership can point the way
forward second
workforces are used to getting trained
and acquiring new skills at work
it's one of the few places that we
achieve
norms and skill development and at scale
after we become adults
and finally work is one place where we
as americans do tend to bump up against
people with different
backgrounds beliefs and values something
that's becoming more rare in all other
parts of our lives so it's a perfect
place not only to learn but also to
practice
skills of listening bridging problem
solving and social cohesion so well put
it is abundantly clear that the skills
we teach
can be so helpful to our students
to their colleagues that they will have
in the future in the workforce and to
our society
i really really appreciate you
highlighting the value of listening and
strategic communication
now i've been looking forward to this
for a long time kristin before we end
i'd like to ask you the same three
questions i ask everybody who joins me
are you up for that i am if you were to
capture the best communication advice
you ever received as a five to seven
word slide title
what would it be use a microphone and
hold it close to your mouth sorry that's
nine words
[Music]
so
i know you're big on amplifying your
message i'm curious why of all the
things you could have said did you
choose to say that
it's the simplest thing but if your
audience can't hear you they're gonna
tune out and you don't want that to
happen
and i know you have so many suggestions
for how to get your audience's attention
to sustain that attention and you're
right if they can't hear you they can't
listen and learn question number two
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe i'd be remiss if i didn't share
the advice we give our students quarter
after quarter
know your audience
know your context
and know your speaking goal what is it
you want that audience to leave
thinking feeling and doing differently
because they've just listened to you
there you go folks you don't have to
attend our class you got it all in
three key ideas know your audience know
your context and know your goal
who is a communicator that you admire
and why
well matt in saying this i'm ending our
talk on a somewhat more serious note but
my answer to this question has to be
ukrainian president philodomer zelinski
talk about knowing your audience your
context and your speaking goal i mean
well literally under fire he has the
presence and the composure to explain
what he needs whether from the ukrainian
people from russia or from western
democracies i'm floored amazed and
humbled absolutely it has been truly
remarkable to see somebody under the
pressures and stresses that are going on
to communicate so clearly
and so passionately
kristen
thank you so much for being here
you know i love collaborating with you
and learning from you and i
love the fact that our audience gets to
learn from you as well thanks for
sharing your insights and ideas with all
of us and thanks for not sharing any of
the embarrassing stories you have about
me
it's been a pleasure matt
[Music]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by stanford university's
graduate school of business for more
information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu
or subscribe to our show wherever you
get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
stanford.gsb